meet the lg one quick flex it's now the
perfect tool for everything you need
from work to play and everything in
between the device is also handy for
recreation and leisure so home workouts
with one-on-one coaching or even cooking
at home there are a lot of fun and
creative ways of using the lg one quick
flex so you don't have to only use it
for work or serious business
the pandemic has changed the way we work
and play companies have been made to
transform their workplace culture to a
work from home culture and what was once
a privilege working from home has now
become a new normal way of working
everyone has been adapting to the new
work from home culture but working from
home needs to be handled the right way
by setting up a dedicated work area and
having the best items to enhance your
experience think better productivity and
achieving a better work-life balance
whether it's an office chair or perhaps
an adjustable desk it's all about making
your workplace at home more comfortable
and productive and what we all need is
the right equipment or rather one anchor
item that can transform the way we work
what we have here is lg's latest take on
4k interactive displays
meet the lg one quick flex originally
designed as a commercial display for
businesses the lg one quick flex is now
the perfect tool for everything you need
from work to play and everything in
between but first let's take a look at
what's under the hood and on it the
color profile here moves beyond the
conventional black you see on other tvs
and the quick flex comes with a more
stylish beige that makes it fit into any
home the quick flex comes in two parts
there's the adjustable rolling stand and
of course the 4k display
the screen is 43 inches of sharp
detailed and amazingly beautiful real
estate with a native resolution of 3840
by 2160 pixels and an ips panel with a
response time of 9 milliseconds at the
rear we have a bunch of connectivity
options so we're gonna split this into
two sides the av side has a usb type-c
and two hdmi inputs and at the pc side
we have a usb type-c port a usb a port
and an ethernet lan port as well yes you
heard it right the lg one quick flex is
powered by windows making this a super
all-in-one computer television and touch
device in one on the pc side this bad
boy is powered by amd ryzen r1505g
cpu a radeon vega gpu and four gigabytes
of ram including an internal storage of
128 gigabytes boy that's a lot of stuff
now of course it's not going to hit that
caliber of let's say a gaming pc but
with the lg one quick flex it has
performed pretty well in terms of
productivity we're talking about opening
multiple chrome tabs documentation
video conferencing hey surfing the
internet it's all been a smooth sailing
experience and you can expect the lg-1
quick flex to be a decent daily driver
now you're probably wondering what this
bar is over here on top of the monitor
and that is the camera air microphone
and it's all seamlessly formed into one
whole package you get a full hd
1920x1080 resolution out of the camera
with an 88 degree field of view so
whether you're alone we have a few
colleagues who want to video call
someone with your entire extended family
you're gonna get a nice wide angle here
alongside that comes the optional
movable stand the caster wheels make it
easy to move around and there are bricks
on it too
you can rotate the screen into portrait
mode if you need the extra vertical
space which also means you can make
slight height adjustments to the mount
to meet your posture or height with this
mobility you can already see how it fits
into some scenarios say you would like
to move this into your children's room
for a quick lesson before getting on a
call in your study how about a video
game session before turning it into a
collaborative tool for work think of the
lg one quick flex as an open slate for
what you can do to it and the
possibilities it brings it is a 43 inch
4k tv that's meant to solve the at the
times lonely experience of collaborating
with others remotely so going into the
user experience with the quick flex is
nothing short of spectacular we like to
think of it like a blown up kids tablet
because it's fun and interactive and it
doesn't take itself too seriously the
entire display offers in-cell touch
technology with up to 10 points of
control dedicated full touch pen support
and whiteboard functionality this allows
for gestures and having multiple fingers
touching the screen and you can also
incorporate the included touch pen that
comes with the quick flex if you don't
want your fingerprints blemishing its
awesome display
you've also got a handy dandy remote as
well it's got quick function buttons for
easy access to shortcuts like the camera
app
on top of that you can also perform key
functions through voice commands without
ever having the need to touch the screen
the lg one quickflex is dedicated to
taking down notes drawings and having
collaboration both offline and online so
what makes it a big deal is it changes
the way you collaborate with your
colleagues or students lg has really
done a great job in making these
activities more engaging and personal
using microsoft whiteboard here i can
easily add gerald into the online
session and he can interact with his
tablet or even on his computer and
pitching ideas so we're discussing shoot
locations and putting in a mood board
and if i want to add the address of the
place i can just snip it and insert it
into the white board simple as that we
also have lg's dedicated one quick
remote meeting and think of this like
the zoom app or google meet but even
more intuitive you can host multiple
rooms dedicated to video conferencing
document sharing screen sharing and even
a seminar mode where you can have one
speaker and an audience can even
schedule meetings record them and add
meeting minutes on the fly so whether
you're doing office work at home or
perhaps video conferencing the lg one
quick flex allows you to take down notes
easily and for the little ones they can
do it for the same purpose as well the
device is also handy for recreation and
leisure so home workouts with one-on-one
coaching or even cooking at home there
are a lot of fun and creative ways of
using the lg one quick flex so you don't
have to only use it for work or serious
business even for us the lg one quick
flex proved to be a very useful tool in
our live streaming sessions for say
stream casting in real time and when it
came to collaborative work in and out of
the studio we were able to share our
files and save them to our mobile phones
so you can see how the lg one quick flex
is really well flexible when it comes to
different scenarios and i'm sure you
probably have cool and creative ideas to
really maximize this glorious piece of
tech and this is just the beginning lg
is going to roll out more content and
more integrations to really make this an
all-in-one solution for productivity and
recreation and that's the lg one quick
flex in a nutshell offering something
fresh and familiar at the same time and
if you'd like to learn more details do
check out the link in the description
below follow us on our socials and let
us know if the lg one quick flex appeals
to you and why
let us know down in the comments and
until then this is zeki signing off
adios
[Music]